whether they're set under the sea or out
of this world pixar animated films
transport audiences to infinity
and beyond but the core of the studio's
heartfelt and award-winning stories is
often friendship
from lovable monsters to romantic robots
to prehistoric pals these are the
greatest friendships in pixar history
mike the little green monster with one
big eye and sully his close buddy who is
a furry blue behemoth
are dynamic scarers in 2001's monsters
inc
they collect scream energy to power the
city of monstropolis by popping out of
bedroom closets to frighten children
each night
these two friends are also roommates
with mike coaching sully to sharpen his
scaring skills and use his best
scary feet scary feet scary feet scary
feet oh the kid's awake
okay scary feet scary feet scared feet
scared scared kids to sleep
however their friendship doesn't
actually drive the plot of the film
rather it's sully's connection with buu
the toddler who accidentally tumbles
into the monster world that changes
sully's life
and the scare floor for the better the
little girl wanders through her closet
door and into the monster's factory one
night while sully is working late but
she's
anything but terrified instead she's
curious about this blue beast and
instantly calls him kitty sully and mike
scramble to hide her worried they'll
lose their jobs or worse
become infected with kid germs but when
the girl is afraid to sleep because of
the lizard-like monster who usually
scares her each night
sully promises to watch over her so she
can rest he soon nicknames her boo
because she's great at hiding and
surprising him kicking off an incredibly
close friendship between
cutie and the beast and while he figures
out how to guide her home she shows him
and the rest of the monster world how
powerful laughter can be
inside out is the story of how joy and
sadness become friends while co-existing
inside a tween girl named riley
during this journey joy realizes why
sadness is so important
alongside other feelings like anger fear
and disgust
but nothing tugs that emotions quite
like a goodbye between good friends who
know when it's time to move on and
that's what happens to joy and bing bong
riley's imaginary friend from childhood
created when riley was three bing bong
is a sweet concoction with a cotton
candy body
a cat's tail and whiskers and an
elephant's trunk he even claims to be
part dolphin
[Music]
when joy and sadness become lost during
riley's depression over her family's
move to san francisco they find bing
bong wandering among her memories
joy thinks that he's just what riley
needs to cheer up
even though he misses riley bing bong is
wise beyond his parts
once he joy and his rocket wagon fall
into the memory dump joy despairs
knowing that's where all memories are
forgotten
but bing bong realizes that riley will
need joy throughout her life so he
chooses to sacrifice himself
and launch joy to safety he has just one
heartbreaking
request before fading away take her to
the moon for me
okay
[Music]
when miguel unexpectedly travels to the
land of the dead in 2017's coco
he finds a friend in hector he agrees to
help miguel meet the famous musician who
the boy thinks is his great great
grandfather in exchange for taking
hector's photo
back to the land of the living this is
crucial for hector because
no souls can cross the marigold bridge
and visit their loved ones on day of the
dead unless someone places their photo
on an ofrenda sure hector is a pretty
mischievous character disguising himself
as none other than mexican artist frida
kahlo
in one of his many attempts to cross the
bridge and he looks pretty raggedy even
for a skeleton
but he's a sincere soul who's just
desperate he wants to see his daughter
again because he died when she was just
a child
and now her memories of him are fading
it takes some help from miguel's late
extended family the ale brije papita
and the dog dante to sort out hector's
true connection to miguel but even
before then the two have an easy going
playful chemistry perfectly on display
in their rousing performance of
un poco loco which completely captivates
a festival audience
there was never any doubt that marlin an
overprotective clownfish
needed the support of dory in the
heartfelt film finding nemo
after marlin's only child nemo is
scooped up by a diver near
the great barrier reef he nearly has a
breakdown marlin wouldn't have been able
to swim five feet
let alone all the way to nemo's aquarium
in a dentist office in sydney australia
without dory by his side
she's outgoing enough to ask for
directions she's a patient companion
and she can speak whale a widower who
lost his wife and dozens of eggs to a
barracuda
marlin is understandably nervous but his
doom and gloom outlook threatens to get
the better of him when nemo goes missing
when he begs for help dozens of assorted
fish pass him by
dory is the only one who stops to lend
her assistance even though her cheerful
disposition and short-term memory loss
test marlin's patience at first
she turns out to be just the right
partner for such an arduous journey
she nudges marlin along at every hurdle
whether it's by bouncing a top jellyfish
chatting with various undersea creatures
or flying with pelicans
as she reminds marlon when circumstances
look rough sometimes you've gotta just
keep swimming
when life gets you down you know what
you gotta do i don't wanna know what you
gotta do just keep swimming
just keep swimming just keep swimming
swimming swimming
pixar's brilliant science fiction film
wall-e is a charming romance that
focuses on two robots who only possess
about nine words between them but they
seem to share a connection that
transcends language
wally is the last functioning robot on
earth he's a stout compactor who spends
his days cleaning up
endless miles of trash but he also
treasures some of the artifacts he
discovers such as a spork and a rubik's
cube
he hangs out with a cockroach that
chirps like a cricket but also seems to
be achingly lonely as he watches old
videos of musicals and gazes at the
stars
so it's no wonder that he falls head
over treads at the first sight of
eve a sleek egg-shaped bot who can fly
eve scans the earth for any signs of
vegetation so that all humans cruising
in space can one day return to the
planet
but she's cagey about her mission and
takes her time warming up to wally
nevertheless she eventually recognizes
his thoughtfulness and sheltering her
from a sandstorm
his whimsy and showing her the outdated
wonders of his home and of course his
awesome dance moves
it's only after he safeguards her
mission by protecting a seedling that
their initial spark blooms into one of
pixar's most unique and memorable
relationships
in 2007's ratatouille food critic anton
ego
writes something that is touching and
profound not everyone can become
a great artist but a great artist
can come from anywhere the same can be
said for a great friend as remy a rat
with refined culinary tastes and
linguine a clumsy kitchen assistant
learn while cooking up a storm together
voiced by patton oswalt
remy doesn't fit in with his rat colony
which loves eating whatever disgusting
scraps humans throw away
eventually remy winds up in the kitchen
of a famous restaurant in paris
for him this is paradise but nobody
wants a rat around food
even one as tidy as remy however when he
tries to sneak out of the kitchen to
save his hide
he stops to salvage a soup that the ever
clumsy linguine has ruined he ends up
creating an amazing dish as well as
earning linguine some serious praise
the insecure young man soon realizes
that this little chef can understand him
and has the type of creativity in the
kitchen that he can only dream of
the two friends eventually discover how
to cook together with remy hiding under
linguine's chef hat and tugging on his
hair
but once they truly learn to trust each
other this method proves
unnecessary and they figure out a way to
let each of their talents shine
while remy and linguini struggle through
some sour moments it's nothing that a
good talk and a delicious meal can't
solve
russell an enthusiastic young wilderness
explorer and carl an elderly man tied to
his house in more ways than one
are probably the most unlikely pair of
pixar friends
in fact the animators even designed this
duo from 2009's up with opposite shapes
in mind
russell is rounded like a top because
he's an energetic dervish while the
widowed carl is
so set in his ways that his face body
and eyeglasses resemble sturdy squares
the two strangers end up on a thrilling
journey together after the isolated man
comes up with a whimsical plan to avoid
being sent to a retirement home
instead he sets off for paradise falls a
south american waterfall that his late
wife
always wanted to see of course what
makes this trip so extraordinary
is that he's traveling in his house
which is attached to thousands of helium
balloons
russell who is eager to earn a badge for
assisting the elderly
happens to be on the porch when the
building takes flight
it takes a while for them to really get
along carl is pretty cranky after all
but
this odd couple ends up perfectly
balancing one another
they even discover that something as
simple as sharing ice cream can be an
adventure if you're with someone you
care about
and honestly it's impossible to not get
choked up during the scene where carl
shows up for russell's wilderness
explore ceremony to award the boy in
honor in his late wife's name released
in 2015 the good dinosaur takes place in
an alternate past where the asteroid
thought to have destroyed the dinosaurs
just
barely misses earth so instead dinosaurs
and humans end up
sharing the earth together at the same
time it's in this prehistoric setting
that a very unusual friendship forms
arlo a young apatosaurus who comes from
a family of farmers runs across a feral
child who is lost and far from home
arlo initially fights with the boy for
eating his family's corn but eventually
grows close to him and names him spot
despite arlo's tendency to be afraid he
even tries to protect the boy
or at least make sure that he doesn't
get eaten spot on the other hand
is fearless he grabs lizards snakes and
occasionally bites the heads off of
giant bugs
still he seems to be glad that someone
bigger has his back
the boy teaches arlo how to howl
snuggles against him when he sleeps and
scampers up his neck to ride on the
dinosaur's head
meanwhile arlo twirls his tail in the
grass to enchant the boy with fireflies
he also matures enough through the film
to realize when to leave spot in caring
human hands
their friendship may not have lasted
very long but memories of their moments
together
definitely will oh look look it gives
you the little gooses
every time i love that story
perhaps the greatest pixar friendship of
all time launched the animation studios
empire with a simple but relatable
narrative
toy story is the tale of a cloth cowboy
who isn't the top toy in a boy's life
anymore after a confident space
ranger arrives with flashing lights and
fancy sound effects
the voice talents of tom hanks and tim
allen infuse woody and buzz with tons of
personality
in fact the character's evolving
friendship has kept audiences enthralled
for more than 20 years
however the two toys had a rocky start
when a jealous woody accidentally causes
buzz to fall from a bedroom window and
that wasn't the last time that they had
a disagreement
luckily their bond has survived many
challenges including nearly being blown
to bits
a madcap chase around an airport an
extremely dicey daycare center and a
very close call with a blazing
incinerator at a garbage dump
whatever their ups and downs may be they
always figure out how to soar
woody and buzz have plenty of their own
insecurities wondering what lies ahead
for them
but they know how to encourage each
other when it's needed whether they're
discussing
how noble it is to be a child's toy or
letting a pal know that it's okay to
follow his heart for a change
like the best human friends buzz and
woody might travel to unexpected places
or find themselves with different
families but no matter what they can
always count on
one thing when it all ends i'll have old
buzz lightyear to keep me company
for infinity and beyond check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite films are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]